on
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
mode d'emploi l'été arrive
vous êtes étudiant et vous allez
chercher à jabba ça tombe bien cette
semaine nous allons parler animations
c'est un secteur qui recrute pour les
vacances bien sûr mais il faut savoir
que les métiers de l'animation ça se
pratique toute l'année on voit ça tout
de suite après votre sommaire cette
semaine je vous emmène à l'ifac
l'institut de formation d'animation et
de conseil des yvelines
ici vous pourrez vous former aux métiers
de l'animation mais également obtenir
des diplômes pour vous perfectionner
nous parlerons ensuite recrutement si
les jobs de vacances vient de démarrer
sachez que l'on prépare actuellement les
embauches de septembre vous découvrirez
les postes les plus demandés et les
opportunités pour les retardataires du
mois d'août
en plus des jobs des vacances destiné
essentiellement aux étudiants
l'animation socioculturelle gagne du
terrain
la réforme sur les rythmes scolaires des
berges du temps libre consacré aux
activités périscolaires
par conséquent les emplois de
l'animation se développent et s'adresse
aujourd'hui aussi bien aux jeunes qu'aux
familles et même aux seniors pour vous
permettre d'y voir plus clair
décortiquons ensemble ce vaste domaine
le secteur de l'animation fonctionne
toute l'année
en france plus de cent mille salariés
travaillent dans cette branche et dans
les yvelines
on compte plus d'une centaine de
personnes aussi bien dans le secteur
public que dans le privé
l'animation englobe aussi bien les jobs
de vacances donc occasionnels que
l'animation à l'année des métiers à part
entière
l'animation touches différentes
activités tourisme culture sociale et de
nombreuses spécialités danse musique
multimédia
l'animateur peut travailler avec un
public très varié des tout jeunes au
public en difficulté en passant par des
personnes âgées
l'éventail des tâches est également très
large et peut aller de l'animation du
public aux activités périscolaires à la
gestion d'un service ou à la mise en
place de manifestations
enfin les contrats varient du temps
partiel au temps plein le cdi ou cdd ou
en vacation un animateur que démarrer au
smic
en commençant par de l'encadrement en
centre de vacances puis gravir des
échelons et finir coordinateur quel que
soit le contrat pour travailler dans
l'animation occasionnels il vous faudra
au minimum un bafa diplôme non
professionnels et avoir 17 ans révolus
pour en faire votre métier
plusieurs diplômes sont possibles et
vous offriront de nombreux sports dans
de nombreux secteurs
vous l'avez vu l'animation offre un
large choix de possibilités
je vous invite à présent à découvrir les
diplômes qui vous permettront d'exercer
dans l'animation
selon vos affinités c'est à l'ifac et
c'est tout de suite l'institut de
formation d'animation et de conseil des
yvelines intervient au service des
collectivités dans plus de soixante
commune yvelinoise on est spécialisée
dans l'information sur des diplômes
professionnels mais aussi sur d
diplômes dits non professionnels comme
le bafa qui sont des brevets d'aptitude
bien qu'elle ne soit pas
professionnalisantes la formation au
bafa permet d'acquérir de bonnes bases
en animation en trois étapes la première
du coup c'est un stage qu'on appelle
formation générale qui dure 10 jours en
centre de formation
la deuxième étape c'est un stage
pratique de 14 jours minimum en accueil
de loisirs ou en séjour vacances est la
dernière étape d'un approfondissement où
on va approfondir un thème particulier
pendant six jours à l'issue de la
formation il est possible d'animer pour
un jeune public dans des centres de
loisirs ou de vacances c'est le cas
d'adrien et de marie qui ont commencé
avec un bafa avant de se
professionnaliser dans ce secteur qui
demande de nombreuses qualités
la patience il faut beaucoup
d'imagination avec fin surtout avec les
maternelles pour renouveler les
activités ce qu'on leur raconte un
escalier mais bien sûr les enfants les
plus grandes qualités ça va être le
relationnel déjà donc que ce soit avec
les enfants les parents et l'équipe
d'animation
ensuite la ponctualité est râleur
souriant motivant motivé ma faut
toujours être au top on ne peut pas voir
de coup de mou il le sent qu'ils ne
savent qu'on n'est pas bien la
créativité être capable de
de créer construire des choses avec les
enfants donc quand je dis construire ce
n'est pas forcément construire des
objets mais construire une relation un
environnement pour les enfants une
activité qui demande également une très
grande disponibilité
c'est des horaires larges pendant les
vacances scolaires donc ses 48 heures de
travail par semaine pendant l'année
scolaire c'est des journées à trous on
travaille en alternance avec les maîtres
et maîtresses
quand je travaillais pas nous on
travaille avant l'école de 7h30 à 8h30
le midi à la cantine et le soir ça peut
être 18h30 pour certains centres 19
heures jusqu'à 20 heures pour d'autres
centres de loisirs
on va avoir une vingtaine d'heures dans
la semaine plus les travail de
préparation qui nous emmèneront entre 30
et 33 heures un métier ouvert à tous dès
l'âge de 17 ans en reconversion
professionnelle beaucoup d'animateurs
qui ont commencé une carrière dans un
domaine tout autre que l'animation
arrive souvent et passent leur bafa ou
un autre diplôme pour pouvoir travailler
dans l'animation si adrien est
aujourd'hui directeur adjoint c'est
parce qu'il a eu la possibilité
d'acquérir des formations qualifiantes
à la suite de son bafa nous pouvons
mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle des passerelles vers
l'apprentissage donc c'est un dispositif
d'accès à l'apprentissage qui permet à
des jeunes n'ayant pas forcément de
qualification spécifique dans le métier
de pouvoir accéder par cette formation à
une formation qualifiante le bats pas tu
es le premier niveau professionnel dans
l'animation il permet d'acquérir une
formation diplômante d'assistant
animateur technicien et permet de
travailler aussi bien en accueil de
loisirs qu'on activités périscolaires
c'est l'animateur de bad avec beaucoup
plus de connaissances théoriques qu'un
bafa de par la longueur de la formation
bapat se déroule sur un an
donc deux jeunes ont largement de quoi
apprendre et mettre en pratique c'est ce
qui fait la différence avec un bafa donc
les trois domaines de compétences et
activités manuelles ces sports
collectifs et ses jeux de société jeux
extérieurs donc c'est les trois domaines
de compétences validé pour après pouvoir
passer devant le jury pour valider son
son papa tu un jury simulés par le
professeur et qui met les futurs
candidats en conditions
vianney est très motivé car pour lui
l'animation est une reconversion totale
et il n'a pas l'intention de s'arrêter
là en fait à l'origine moi je suis
diplômé de restauration mais par la
suite on fait les entreprises que
j'essaie de postuler nous pas refuser
donc j'ai passé un an au chômage jusqu'à
définitivement me dire que j'étais ou
que je voulais faire le bafa et par
l'affrontement entre la mairie au
chemin-bas encourager encore plus à
pousser au delà du bafa donc depuis je
passe le bats pas tu refuses si ça
continue je fais continuer les autres
diplômes qui vont suivre avec que
j'essaie de faire en fait c'est le
diplôme de moniteur éducateur vous
faites pour des sommes de mauvais
centres dont fo pour difficulté ne va
pas te permet ensuite d'évoluer vers
d'autres diplômes comme le bpjeps
sportifs ou socioculturel un diplôme de
niveau bac qui permet de démarrer avec
un salaire de 1500 euros net
il ya tout un tout un panel de bp jette
beaucoup plus de bp jeps sportif que de
bp jeps animation socioculturelle en
général l'animation culturelle ce sera
le loisir le loisir tout public où
l'animation sociale un diplôme qui
permet l'accès aux fonctions
d'encadrement avec une fourchette de
salaire variable de l'ordre de 1600 à
2000 100 euros avec le bpjeps loisirs
tous publics le bpjeps qui contient du
coup le module de direction on peut du
coup devenir directeur de centre de
loisirs de manière professionnelle avec
un statut reconnu donc on dit un
directeur de centre de loisirs pour des
communes qui gèrent leurs centres de
loisirs pour des associations qui gèrent
leurs centres de loisirs mais on peut
aussi être directeur de colonie de
vacances par exemple et surtout bpjeps
permet d'alléger des centres de loisirs
des accueils de loisirs de plus de 80
enfants 7
du coup on verra
différentes différents contenus on verra
tout ce qui est communication et
management pour pouvoir gérer une équipe
et managez une équipe
on verra tout ce qui est réglementation
et on verra tout ce qui a trait aussi
connaissance du public donc psychologie
de l'enfant besoins de l'enfant et
comment y répondre
si on veut pousser un peu plus loin peut
aussi par exemple c'est mon cas moi je
suis passé du côté formation du coup
donc maintenant je suis référent de
formation professionnelle avec encore la
possibilité de passer sur neuf mois un
dejeps avec des fonctions de
coordination autour de la législation
comment comment gérer aussi pas mal de
choses au niveau de la communication de
la gestion d' équipe de masse et puis
niveau encore au dessus qui est le
dejeps ce type de diplôme permet d'avoir
un poste comme le mien par exemple
coordinateur d'un territoire
ça peut être aussi la coordination d'une
grande commune où il ya énormément de
structures à gérer toutes ces formations
se déroulent sur un an de septembre à
septembre afin de se caler sur
l'éducation nationale et permettre aux
jeunes diplômés de trouver un emploi dès
la rentrée à présent pour ceux et celles
qui auraient déjà leur diplôme c'est le
moment de s'en servir et d'envoyer vos
cv je vous laisse découvrir où quand et
comment
en plus de ces formations diplômantes
l'ifac travaille également au
recrutement de l'ensemble des accueils
de loisirs pour les collectivités ça
passe effectivement du recrutement des
équipes mais aussi à tout
l'administratif et donc quand
effectivement quand on reçoit des des cv
des lettres de motivation des communes
ou des centres de loisirs ont
recentralise tous ici au siège pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir répondre au mieux
aux attentes et aux demandes
la réforme sur les rythmes scolaires a
permis de dégager du temps libre par
conséquent les emplois de l'animation se
sont développées et aujourd'hui l'ifac
recherche pour de nombreuses
collectivités des animateurs d'activités
périscolaires donc actuellement on est
en train de recruter pour pour la
rentrée la septembre 2017 2018
et en terme de recrutement c'est vrai
qu'on attend beaucoup finalement des
animateurs qu'un seulement de la
surveillance dans la cour on attend bien
plus que cela on attend que l'animateur
soit attentif et à l'écouté auprès des
enfants qu'il y ait une bonne
communication avec ses collègues donc
avec son équipe et qui soit vraiment
moteur est un modèle pour tous
finalement surtout pour les plus jeunes
il faut qu'ils puissent proposer tout un
panel d'activités diverses et variées
c'est important entre le sport le manuel
l'expression et qu'ils défendent
certaines valeurs qui nous tiennent à
coeur comme le savoir faire et être en
collectivité des animateurs avec malgré
tout un bagage ou une première
expérience dans l'animation des
animateurs qui ont aumoins démarrer le
bafin pour respecter les quotas
d'encadrement et puis après si ça va au
delà du bafa on est preneur également en
termes de rémunération pour les
animateurs ben quand il n'est pas
diplômé c'est vraiment le minimum est
donc l'oeuf le smic et plus on évolue
dans le diplôme ou dans le brevet plus
le taux horaire augmente finalement donc
quand on a un bafa il augmente quand on
a un papa tu il augmente aussi
pareil pour le bbd ou pour le bpjeps des
contrats tout d'abord en cdd qui
évolueront rapidement en cdi
afin de pérenniser ces postes
accessibles à tous de 17 ans à 50 ans et
plus si on veut candidate et il faut
envoyer un cv une lettre de motivation
par courrier au siège au siège de l'ifac
ou par mail également mais aussi auprès
d'eux des directeurs qui sont sur site
parce que des fois c'est plus facile
aussi d'ailleurs leur apporter un cv la
démotivation à côté de là où on habite
et nous on nous leur transmet pour qu'on
puisse faire le tri et pouvoir répondre
à tout le monde dans les plus brefs
délais sachez également que yvelines
information jeunesse propose sur son
site un service de petites annonces
si vous êtes à la recherche d'un job
étudiant ou d'un emploi saisonnier pour
ce mois d'août
ces annonces sont également disponibles
sur la page facebook et sur le compte
twitter
n'hésitez pas également à consulter et à
télécharger le guide 2010 est trouvé un
job il fourmille d'informations et de
conseils pour vous aider dans vos
démarches de recherche d'emploi
l'information jeunesse est présente sur
le territoire venez rencontrer ses
conseillers dans l'une des 30 structures
des yvelines
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
bonne chance dans les métiers de
l'animation et si vous avez encore des
questions
n'oubliez pas que la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines peut vous
aider à monter votre projet
professionnel
sachez toutefois qu'elle ferme ses
portes du 31 juillet au 21 août à 13h30
mais il vous sera possible de voir le
programme en ligne courant juillet quant
à moi je vous souhaite de bonnes
vacances et bien sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]